press one to speak with someone about
possibly extending or reinstating your
car's warranty
yep we've all gotten a call like this
one and sure you can just block the
number like i'm going to do
but almost certainly another one's going
to call back the truth is it's
impossible to completely stop all
unwanted calls the fcc says people got 4
billion of them in the us in 2020 4
billion with a b
fortunately there are some ways to deal
with them by either activating some
settings on your iphone or by
downloading third party apps let's talk
about why you're still getting those
calls and what you can do about them
[Music]
basically a robocall is software that
autodials phone numbers and they aren't
all bad pharmacies use them to update
you about your prescription
and your cable provider might use one to
let you know about an outage you opt in
to receive these calls so where did this
all start well before the internet you
needed expensive software to reach a
large number of customers at the same
time from the same number
now anyone can auto dial numbers either
pulled from the web or bought from third
parties the calls might look like
they're coming from someone in your area
code and there might be a human on the
other side trying to convince you to
share sensitive information but don't be
fooled by them
your cell phone carrier probably has
some basic call blocking features you
can use but even with those some
unwanted calls are bound to get through
so what can you do about them in 2019
apple launched its feature to silence
unknown callers and is it perfect
no but it will ensure that you only get
calls from numbers you have saved or
from people you've already talked to
your phone won't ring but the call will
still go to your voicemail the missed
call will still appear in your missed
calls list but you won't have
notifications interrupting your day to
silence unknown callers go to settings
find phone and then scroll down to
silence unknown callers and make sure
it's turned on there is somewhat of a
failsafe built in if you've previously
texted with someone or if they sent you
their phone number in an email those
calls will come through according to
apple but still if it's a call from your
doctor's office your kid's school or
from a delivery person those calls might
get filtered out just save them in your
phone over time to let the system know
who you want to hear from
there are some paid options if you want
to kick things into high gear each of
the mobile carriers has some premium
call blocking features and you can call
them to find out what those are at t for
example offers call protect which
includes reverse call lookup and will
reveal unknown caller details for 3.99 a
month meanwhile t-mobile has scam shield
for four bucks a month and verizon has
call filter plus for 299 a month the app
store is also filled with apps that will
try to block or detect spam calls for
you
and apple allows you to layer the apps
based on priority some popular apps
include robo-killer hiya and truecaller
once you've downloaded the apps there's
one more step to take hit settings go
down to phone and find call blocking and
identification then turn on whichever
call blockers you want to use once
you've turned them on you can tap edit
to move them around and rank them based
on priority
worst case scenario you inadvertently
answer the call and hear something like
this
just hang up
if you like videos like this be sure to
subscribe because there will be more and
comment below and let me know what i
should look into next until next time